When you wear the rings of power, you win
or you die.
Wait, that's not right.
Game of Thrones and Lord of the Rings are
two different shows.
Still, they hold a surprising connection.
While the entire genre of fantasy fiction
owes a huge debt to J.R.R.
Tolkien, the creation of Amazon's first foray
into Middle-earth, "The Lord of the Rings:
The Rings of Power," might be a by-product
of the success of "Game of Thrones."
HBO's adaptation of George R.R.
Martin's "A Song of Ice and Fire" book series
was the ultimate fantasy saga of the 2010s,
inspiring networks and streaming services
to acquire the rights to popular genre IPs.
Without "Game of Thrones," shows such as "The
Witcher" and "The Wheel of Time" might not exist.
Of course, comparisons between the aforementioned
franchises were always inevitable considering
that Amazon's "The Rings of Power" debuted
shortly after the premiere of "House of the
Dragon" on HBO.
Even Martin knows that viewers will pit the
shows against each other in a battle of fantasy
warfare, but he hopes that people can enjoy
both shows on their own accord.
He told the "Independent,"
"I hope both shows succeed.
I'm competitive enough.
I hope we succeed more.
If they win six Emmys, and I hope they do,
I hope we win seven."
At the end of the day, the "Lord of the Rings"
and "Game of Thrones" franchises are unique
entities that bring their own spins to fantasy
fare.
However, that doesn't mean they don't share
some common elements that enable perfectly
understandable comparisons to be made.
Robert Aramayo is the force that binds together
"The Rings Of Power" and "Game of Thrones" franchises.
The 29-year-old English actor has developed
a knack for playing popular characters on
fantasy series, or to be more specific, playing
the younger versions of beloved, established characters.
Aramayo rose to fame by portraying a young
Ned Stark during the sixth season of "Game of Thrones."
He appeared in a series of flashback sequences
that shed some light on Jon Snow's family history.
"No.
Now it ends."
He did an admirable job of honoring the legacy
of Sean Bean, who played the House of Stark
leader during his middle-aged years.
Of course, one does not simply forget that
Sean Bean connected The Lord of the Rings
and Game of Thrones when it premiered in 2011
– so Ned Stark is the true connector between
George RR Martin and JRR Tolkien.
In "The Rings of Power," the Englishman plays
a younger version of Elrond, the legendary
half-elven character who's appeared in every
onscreen "Lord of the Rings" project to date.
The character, who was brought to life by
Hugo Weaving in "Lord of the Rings" and "The
Hobbit," will have a key role to play in the
Amazon series, which was what attracted Aramayo
to the fantasy project in the first place.
The Elrond we meet in "The Lord of the Rings:
The Rings of Power" is slightly different
from the wise and storied warrior we see in
Peter Jackson's movies.
Here, he's not quite the strong, stubborn,
commanding leader that he went on to become.
For a start, he's relatively uninterested
in attending council meetings and concerning
himself with political matters.
Additionally, he's not on the best terms with
some of the elves' allies, though he is able
to use his charm and cunning to get what he
wants during moments of political persuasion.
While speaking to "Variety," Robert Aramayo
revealed that bringing young Elrond to fruition
was exciting as it meant exploring uncharted
territory in some ways.
Furthermore, he doesn't think that "Game of
Thrones" and "The Rings of Power" are anything
alike, with the exception of being fantasy
series that he worked on.
He said,
"They're very, very different shows.
My job on [Game of Thrones] and my job on
[The Rings of Power] were very different."
According to the actor, "Games of Thrones"
allowed him to draw upon material that was
already there for inspiration.
However, since the First and Second Ages of
Middle-earth are open to interpretation in
many ways, "The Rings of Power" allowed him
to essentially build a character from scratch.